Hablamos ahora del festival de cine de
can porque la directora de Justin ties
se convirtió en la tercera mujer en
ganar la palma de oro lo hizo con la
cinta a nation o anatomía de una caída
para hablar de la directora y de su
filme nos acompaña nuestra periodista
especializada en temas de cultural e
Israel lea bienvenida Bueno vamos a
empezar hablando de qué se trata el
filme ganador bueno Valentina anatomía
de una cálida es una película sobre un
juicio pero ante todo es una película
sobre la disección de una pareja La
alemana Sandra olor interpreta su
protagonista principal
cuyo marido murió en una caída doméstica
y durante la investigación policial se
ponen en cuestión todos los detalles de
esta relación casualmente anatomía de
una caída se rodó al mismo tiempo que el
senado juicio contra heard por violencia
doméstica en Estados Unidos y la
directora
dijo que se quedó cautivada siguiendo
los giros de este juicio entre cada toma
de su película en una entrevista de
también lo que me obsesiona es la
judicialización de la intimidad en lugar
donde te cuentan lo que ha pasado en tu
lugar es decir el principio mismo de la
ficción de hecho ella se impuso dos
limitaciones para su cinta no flashbacks
y una verosimilitud absoluta ayudada por
los consejos de un abogado penalista y
es que Justin quiles hizo conocer en
cuatro películas por sus afiliadas y
dolientes radiografías humanas recibir
hoy el prestigioso galardón es también
una directora que aprovechó tener este
espacio para hacer un discurso muy
político sobre su país Francia la
escuchemos
este año el país se ha visto envuelto en
una protesta histórica extremadamente
poderosa y unánime contra la reforma de
las pensiones
contestación esta protesta fue
escandalosamente negada y reprimida y
este patrón de un poder cada vez más
prepotente está irrumpiendo en varios
ámbitos obviamente socialmente es donde
más choca pero también se puede ver en
todas las demás esferas de la sociedad y
el cine No es una excepción la
mercantilización de la cultura que
defiende el gobierno neoliberal está
destruyendo la excepción cultural
francesa
pues Enhorabuena para ti una de las
siete mujeres que estaban siete mujeres
directoras que estaban en esta
competencia y sin duda sigue siendo un
número bastante bajo exactamente
Valentina siete sobre 21 películas esto
es un tercio de la selección oficial
pero no es paridad a pesar de que sea un
récord para toda la historia del
festival Lo bueno es que con este récord
todos los ojos estaban puestos en esas
siete caras y dentro de estas cineastas
podemos destacar a dos directoras
africanas la primera es ramata Tula Yesi
una Franco senegalesa que tiene un
perfil bastante interesante porque es
Era la más joven de toda la selección
oficial y también vanelia dama era su
primera película y también tenemos
avenania que con la película las hijas
de Alfa conmocionó bastante a los
asistentes del festival y con esta
victoria de Justino solamente tres
mujeres en toda la historia del festival
de canan ganado la palma de oro en 76
ediciones Valentina también una cifra
bastante que desesperaba un poquito pero
recordemos que la primera fue la New
Zelanda en 1993 para la lección de piano
esta película que se convirtió en un
clásico del drama y la segunda la ganó
la francesa
hace dos años en 2021 para titán una
película muy fuerte bastante violenta
experimental también pero que a mí me
impactó mucho de todas maneras podemos
afirmar que la paridad en can es una
cuestión complicada hay unas otras
discrepancias entre hombres y mujeres en
esta gran cita de del cine mundial solo
once mujeres han presidido alguna vez el
Jurado por ejemplo pero una buena
noticia que nos llegó este año es que
Iris
exdirectora de Warner Europa se
convierte en la primera mujer en
presidir el festival de canon lea Muchas
gracias por esta ampliación aquí en
France 24 Gracias a ti Valentina y a
ustedes también Muchas gracias por su
sintonía quédense con nosotros que hay
más
[Música]